you have a good deal of voice-acting
experience on your resume so given the
fact that this is so wildly creatively
different was there anything different
for you in terms of the performance
process no if it just it's like
everybody used to say well how can you
do comedy and do drama you just drew
what's on the page or what you
understand and so I could see the style
of this movie is the the voice were in
voice work is becoming more naturalistic
anyway unless you're doing strange
little characters or a little spongebob
or something like that and so this was
this was about humans and real real
people with real problems real conflicts
real loving relationships very diverse
wonderful miles is half Puerto Rican
half half of African American his mother
speaks Spanish he's got a regular thing
with his father like you notice he's
like a 13 year old kid or doesn't want
to like give in to our like his be
embarrassed in front of his peers and
all that stuff and he's got an uncle his
father's brother that was real cool and
interesting and supportive and and he
kind of goes to him when he's adrift and
doesn't know what to do and but they all
are working together to create a real
family and and so and so and there's
Asian characters and there's women
heroes and Gwen Stacy is a wonderful
young girl who's just as powerful as
spider-man in some ways and and it's
just and then they combine cel animation
with computer animation and it's so
innovative and interesting and fun and I
just I just feel like well they just
handed me this it's just a gift I feel
like you give everyone a shout-out
except for yourself Aunt May is the
ultimate badass in this movie and I love
how what she's doing basically embodies
that idea of anyone can wear the mask
she is serving
more than anyone anyone can wear the
mask that's such a nice touch yeah that
is how is it working on something like
this with three directors are they all
there with you giving you notes or do
each one of them have a specific
specialty well I think it was whoever
was free that day when I would show up
they were just sent over one of the
directions I worked I worked with one
director I own I was only there about
four times that I recall and and I think
one director I particularly worked with
a couple of times so he's seeing I
worked with him at the-- on the land
they were quite a distance apart and so
I know it was it was our they were all
of his like mind and I like creativity
and it was just it was great it was very
easy and lovely so at Collider we do a
show called Collider for your
consideration where we get the
opportunity to just celebrate movies out
there that could be up for award
consideration and one of the things that
we're always debating especially with
personal opinion and also the changing
Academy and the changing type of movie
that we see getting recognized every
year is what does an oscar movie mean to
you personally what does it mean to you
so I wanted to pose that question to you
oh well god this would be the way he's
ever been an animated movie that won an
Oscar I think there was one nominated a
couple nominated for Best Picture I
don't know if it's ever won Best Picture
though that would be just sort of
dazzling but for me an Oscar picture is
it could be anything so it could be this
it's you it's usually just something
that works from beginning to end and
it's fills you up with something good
you know either it's crushingly true and
makes you and fills you with belch
merits for this shot for the planet and
for the population or something vibrant
and alive and just makes you want to go
out and wear the masks but so I guess
this is a real possibility
[Music]